L'un des plus fabuleux trésors
de la planète se cache en Équateur.
Des tonnes d'or et d'argent.
Le trésor du dernier empereur Inca,
il s'appelait Atahualpa.
Les conquistadors espagnols
l'ont tué il y a 500 ans,
sa momie est quelque part
dans les Andes.
Une historienne Équatorienne
est sur ses traces depuis dix ans.
Son enquête n'est pas sans risques.
Comme je n'avais pas de gants
pour me protéger les mains,
j'ai été contaminée.
Pas seulement les doigts,
la gorge aussi.
Pour percer le secret de l'énigme,
rien ne l'arrête.
Je peux juste te dire
qu'il se trouve au bout d'un tunnel.
Il pense que le trésor
est au fond d'un tunnel.
D'un bout à l'autre
des Andes équatoriennes,
Tamara cherche inlassablement
la momie de Atahualpa
et son fabuleux trésor.
Des textes soigneusement calligraphiés,
vieux de 500 ans.
C'est entre ces lignes
que se cachent les indices d'une énigme
qui a fait rêver
des générations d'aventuriers.
Tamara Estupiñan est la première
à avoir réussi à les déchiffrer.
Elle est historienne et boursière
de l'Institut français d'études andines.
Dans ce manuscrit du XVIᵉ siècle,
se trouve
le testament du fils d'Atahualpa.
Il s'agit du livre
de Protocol notarial.
Il s'appelait
Don Francisco Tupac Atauchi.
Je suis la première
à l'avoir déchiffré et publié
et surtout d'avoir fait cette découverte
d'une valeur incalculable.
La signature du fils d'Atahualpa.
Je pense que mon enquête
est sur le point d'être bouclée.
Je crois savoir où aurait été caché
le corps de l'empereur Inca,
c'est-à-dire le saint sanctuaire.
Sa découverte
a fait l'effet d'une bombe.
Grande nouvelle en Equateur,
la dernière demeure du grand empereur Inca
Atahualpa, aurait été localisée.
Immédiatement, l'information est reprise
dans le monde entier.
Atahualpa est l'un
des derniers mythes en archéologie,
car près de sa momie,
il y a peut-être son fabuleux trésor.
Les Andes équatoriennes
parmi les plus hautes d'Amérique latine.
Les pistes créées par les Incas
ont simplement été élargies.
Sinon, ici, rien n'a vraiment changé.
Tamara retourne vers le site
qu'elle a découvert
avec celui qui lui sert d'assistant,
son mari Rahim.
Les cols sont perpétuellement balayés
par de violents orages,
les routes à la limite du praticable.
C'est à une centaine de kilomètres
au sud de Quito, la capitale,
que Tamara est persuadée d'avoir localisé
la dernière demeure de l'empereur.
Sur les contreforts
des montagnes andines,
un escalier caché
dans la forêt tropicale.
Les marches taillées dans la pierre
mènent jusqu'à d'étranges ruines.
Une place en forme de trapèze.
Des canaux et un bassin.
Pour Tamara,
il n'y a aucun doute.
Ce type de construction
comme ce canal est spectaculaire.
Regardez, ce canal souterrain
vient de là-haut
pour acheminer l'eau de la montagne
jusqu'ici, sous nos pieds.
Là, c'est une architecture formidable.
On voit bien
que ce chemin est aligné.
Ça, ce type de constructions, on ne
les retrouve que sur des sites impériaux,
bien sûr, de type inca.
C'est l'endroit le plus sacré.
Ici on plaçait
la momie de l'Empereur,
pour qu'il soit face au soleil,
en plein sud.
Là-bas,
ils la lavaient et la séchaient.
Puis, il l'assoyait ici
pour prendre le soleil.
Cet emplacement était vraiment sacré.
Pour confirmer sa découverte,
Tamara attend
le démarrage des fouilles
qui doivent avoir lieu
à la saison sèche.
Pour elle,
tous les indices concordent.
Probablement, c'était ici
comme une tour de guet,
pour surveiller les alentours.
Avant, il y avait un mur,
il vient de s'effondrer.
Oui, il y a encore un mois,
il était debout ce mur.
Pour Tamara,
il faut vite protéger le site.
Tout peut s'effondrer.
Ces ruines incas sont
aujourd'hui occupées par un fermier.
Là où serait cachée
la momie du fils du soleil,
sont maintenant élevées
des coqs de combat.
Dans ma famille, on croyait
que tout cela avait été construit
par le grand-père de mon père.
Grâce à Dieu,
tout a été plutôt bien conservé.
Nous, on n'a jamais rien détruit.
On a compris
qu'il s'agit de ruines Incas,
très importantes
et c'est tout à fait normal
que nous partions.
Nous allons donc
nous installer plus bas dans la vallée.
En attendant
le départ des paysans,
l'État a dépêché un policier
pour surveiller les lieux.
Quant au trésor d'Atahualpa,
l'historienne est persuadée
qu'il n'est pas avec le corps.
Elle doit continuer sa quête.
L'or Atahualpa,
cela fait cinq siècles qu'on le cherche.
Tout remonte à la conquête espagnole
au XVIᵉ siècle.
Malgré leur faible nombre,
les conquistadors réussissent
à capturer l'empereur qui règne
alors sur un tiers de l'Amérique du Sud.
Pour sa libération,
l'Inca propose une rançon.
La première moitié arrive,
elle est colossale,
cinq tonnes d'or
et onze tonnes d'argent.
Les Espagnols prennent peur
et décident d'étrangler leurs prisonniers
qu'ils jugent trop puissants.
À peine enterré par les Espagnols,
le corps de Atahualpa
est dérobé par les Incas
et disparaît
avec le reste de la rançon.
Un trésor dont la valeur
dépasse l'entendement.
À coup sûr,
des centaines de millions d'euros.
Quito était la ville préférée
d'Atahualpa.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est la capitale du pays.
Une ville qui a gommé tout
son héritage inca.
Place San Francisco,
c'est ici que Tamara poursuit sa quête.
Après la momie, elle cherche
des indices sur la localisation du trésor.
Elle a rendez-vous
dans le plus vieux monastère de la ville.
Son plus fidèle informateur,
c'est ce moine franciscain de 90 ans.
Il s'appelle Père Moreno.
Il est le seul à avoir eu
accès aux archives secrètes
du Vatican sur Atahualpa.
Il me donne des indices
au compte-gouttes.
C'est parce qu'il a confiance en moi
et en mon travail,
n'est-ce pas, Père Moreno ?
-Oui.
Et c'est pour cela qu'il faut
que je vous dise,
pour arriver au trésor, il faut...
Le reste, le vieux moine
ne veut pas le dire devant la caméra.
Il emmène l'historienne dans des couloirs
cachés jusqu'à la merveille du monastère.
Une église entièrement recouverte d'or.
C'est spectaculaire.
Combien d'or a-t-il fallu
pour recouvrir tous ces murs ?
Oh ! Impossible à savoir.
Cet or parmi
le plus pur du monde,
c'est celui qui a
rendu fous les conquistadors
et qui continue
d'obséder les équatoriens.
Vous savez où est le trésor ?
-Bien sûr, je le sais.
J'ai étudié toutes les possibilités
et je peux juste dire
qu'il se trouve
au bout d'un tunnel.
Ils pensent que le trésor
est au fond d'un tunnel.
Pour Tamara,
toute information est bonne à prendre
et la conforte
dans ses certitudes.
Ils ont transporté
le cadavre de l'empereur
comme le voulait la coutume,
c'est-à-dire en asseyant
la momie sur une planche
en or massif
de quinze centimètres d'épaisseur.
Ils le portaient
sur leurs épaules comme ça.
Les Incas l'ont déplacé,
mais pas vers le sud de l'Empire,
ni vers le Pérou.
Là-bas, il y avait des soldats espagnols,
alors ils ont dû aller vers le nord,
vers l'équateur.
C'est pour cela que je suis sûr
que la momie est cachée dans notre pays
et le trésor y est aussi.
On sait même
à quoi ressemble ce trésor.
Pour en avoir une petite idée,
allons avec Tamara dans les réserves
de la direction culturelle d'Equateur.
Ici sont stockées les dernières pièces
trouvées dans les tombes
de grands chefs incas.
Ça par exemple,
c'était des boucles incas pour le nez ?
C'était un pectoral ?
On le portait ainsi sur la poitrine,
n'est-ce pas ?
Oui.
Cette pièce-là,
on la mettait bien pour les oreilles ?
Il n'y a là qu'une infime partie
de la richesse des Incas.
En Équateur,
tous ces trésors incroyables
font fantasmer
des bataillons de chercheurs d'or.
Un peu partout dans le pays,
on creuse, on bêche,
on cherche en plein jour,
en famille.
La folie Atahualpa s'empare de tous.
Quand on trouve,
c'est l'euphorie.
Quand je vous disais
que j'avais l'oeil.
Vous voyez ça ?
Il ne l'utilisait pas uniquement
pour cuisiner,
mais aussi pour préparer
les pigments de couleurs
qui servaient ensuite
à peindre leurs céramiques.
Ce qu'il faut noter
sur cette relique,
ce sont ses formes.
Elle a été taillée tout autour.
On reconnait bien
le style de la région.
C'était quelle époque ?
Ceci à au moins 700 ans.
Ces trouvailles finiront peut-être
dans des musées du pays.
Mais en Equateur, les plus belles pièces
se trouvent souvent sur le marché noir.
Nous avons rendez-vous à Quito
chez un revendeur d'objets archéologiques.
Évidemment, tout ce commerce est illégal
et nous le filmons en caméra cachée.
Immédiatement, le trafiquant
nous propose deux statuettes.
Des pièces comme ça
de bonne qualité.
Je crois que ça passe sans problème
dans la valise à la douane.
Ça, c'est très vieux.
Les deux sont très anciennes.
Celle-là a à peu près
4000 avant notre ère.
Et celle-là ?
2000 ans avant notre ère.
Pour le prix, c'est 2 000 $ pour l'une
et un peu moins pour l'autre.
Très très beau.
Si vous voulez
des objets en métal,
j'ai la possibilité
de vous avoir un casque en or.
Inca ou pré Inca ?
C'est pré Inca.
Allô,
comment allez-vous cher ami ?
J'ai un client potentiel
pour le casque.
Il voudrait avoir
une photo d'abord.
Ok, plus tard.
C'est bon pour le casque.
Il en demande 30 000 $.
Voilà les photos
du casque en question.
C'est ce type de trésor qui attire
tant les collectionneurs du monde entier.
De l'or, c'est également
ce que cherche Tamara.
L'historienne vient de finir de traduire
cet imposant manuscrit des conquistadors.
Il lui a donné de nouveaux indices
sur la localisation du trésor d'Atahualpa.
Des pages entourées de mystère
et que l'on ne consulte pas
sans prendre de risques.
Si la chercheuse porte des gants,
c'est pour se protéger.
Quand j'ai découvert ce très vieux livre,
il n'était pas encore restauré
et il était recouvert
de champignon invisible à l'œil nu.
Je n'avais pas de gants
pour me protéger les mains,
j'ai donc été contaminé.
Pas seulement les doigts,
la gorge aussi.
La gorge,
j'ai pu rapidement la soigner.
Pour les mains,
le traitement a duré un an,
je ne pouvais pas être en contact
avec l'eau pendant tout ce temps,
sinon ça aurait contaminé
tout mon corps.
Dans ce testament, il est fait mention
d'une propriété à koutiriki.
C'est écrit :
je n'ai plus de 1000 têtes de bétails
sur l'assise de l'attaque
Tounga dans la province de Koutiriki.
Les recherches avancent.
Le Trésor semble
à portée de main.
Grâce aux documents d'époque
qu'elle a réunis,
Tamara a localisé un terrain
qui appartenait au fils de l'Empereur.
Chose étrange,
il se trouve juste à côté des ruines Inca
où Tamara est persuadée
d'avoir localisé la momie.
Il se trouve
à deux heures de route de Quito.
La propriété du fils d'Atahualpa a
été transformée en sanctuaire catholique,
mais l'endroit était déjà
sacré du temps des Incas.
Aujourd'hui sur les murs,
des milliers de photos et de messages
sous forme de prière
et de remerciements.
Je pense que c'est un endroit
de profonde dévotion indigène.
Aujourd'hui, c'est le petit Jésus,
mais à l'époque d'Atahualpa,
c'était déjà
un lieu sacré Inca.
À la place du petit Jésus,
il y avait une figurine
représentant l'Empereur.
Si on regarde bien, il n'y a ici
que des indiens parlant Quechua,
la langue des Incas.
Pour moi, il n'y a pas de doute,
la tradition a traversé les siècles.
C'est une chose difficile
à accepter pour l'Église catholique,
mais je pense que
mon hypothèse est la bonne.
Pour l'historienne,
à l'intérieur de la poupée sacrée,
se trouverait
une relique inca représentant Atahualpa.
Pour en être sûr,
elle doit obtenir l'autorisation
de passer
l'objet saint aux rayons X.
En attendant cet accord,
Tamara veut vérifier
une autre piste.
À quelques kilomètres de là,
en pleine montagne,
elle pense avoir trouvé la dernière clé
de tout le mystère d'éAtahualpa.
Ce serait ici
autour de ce lac volcanique,
qui culmine à près
de 4000 mètres d'altitude.
J'ai trouvé un texte
qui raconte qu'à la fin du XVIᵉ siècle,
un conquistador du nom
de Cantero est venu dans cette région.
Autour de ce lac,
il a découvert
des Incas richement vêtus.
C'était très étrange, car ce n'était
pas une zone où vivaient des Incas,
mais une autre minorité indienne.
Ma théorie, c'est qu'ils gardaient
ce site qui était sacré,
car il se trouvait
sur une ligne sainte
qui relie le lieu
où était conservé la momie,
le culte de l'effigie
de Atahualpa et ce lac.
Pour elle,
ce sont autant de preuves.
Le trésor se trouverait quelque part,
le long de cette ligne sacrée.
Elle en aura le cœur net
dès le début des fouilles archéologiques.
Depuis douze ans,
Tamara consacre
sa vie à la légende d'Atahualpa.
Dans quelques mois,
son enquête touchera
peut-être à sa fin.